the latest footage from Kiev is in stark
contrast to what the world has been
seeing over the past few weeks President
Viktor Yanukovych and opposition leaders
signed a deal that will hopefully put an
end to Ukraine to deadly political
standoff negotiations were brokered by
the EU Germany's foreign minister also
played a role in bringing the two sides
together we are grateful and happy the
same time definitely were able to
contribute to settle the situation or
better to pave the way now for a
political solution which is now in the
hand of the Ukrainians the deal breaks
down as follows the first step forces
the forming of a power-sharing national
unity government this is to be followed
by constitutional reforms then finally
early presidential and parliamentary
elections protesters on Maidan square
say they're relieved even if they're
still skeptical it's new young you give
him we have I don't trust Yanukovych
he's taken a conciliatory stance in the
past but nobody believes him at least I
don't you go it's not enough if this had
happened last week okay but now those
responsible should have resigned aboard
they should be in jail a member of
laghima klitschko's you dar opposition
party brings the security forces their
orders to stand down showing them the
resolution he says you're not needed
here anymore as the government forces
withdraw the protesters might finally
get some much needed rest